antoine bien de ce pays
iphone 6 il encore son vieux iphone 5
dont le contrat est terminé et dont il a
payé tous les frais antoine décide de le
donner à son amie geneviève qu'un rêve
depuis longtemps toute heureuse
geneviève s'empresse de se rendre chez
vidéotron pour faire activer son iphone5
rendu la mauvaise surprise on lui dit
qu'elle doit d'avoir un nichoir jazz
pour faire déverrouiller son iphone et
pour ce déverrouillage rogers exige 50 $
plus taxes entre les jeunes vierges n'en
revient encore des frais pourtant
téléphone avait été complètement pays
par antoine rien n'interdit un
fournisseur de services cellulaires de
verrouiller un appareil c'est à dire de
ne configuré en fonction de son propre
réseau
il doit cependant dit verrouillé à votre
demande
sous certaines conditions et il a le
droit de réclamer des frais pour le
déverrouillage
cependant ces frais doivent être
inscrits dans le contrat
les bell telus rogers et vidéotron de ce
monde exige tous des frais de
déverrouillage le fin mot de l'histoire
les fournisseurs de services cellulaires
veut tellement votre pied que même une
fois votre contrat terminé et vous fait
évident
il reste attaché m